[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du journal de
la rédaction l'essentiel de l'actualité
locale de ce mercredi à 5 octobre et il
sera notamment question du numérique à
l'école le gouvernement veut allouer un
peu plus de 190 millions d'euros à son
développement l académie de versailles
vient de dresser le bilan des actions et
les perspectives envisagées à magny les
hameaux se déroule en ce moment une
semaine citoyenne les plus jeunes
invités à mieux connaître les
différentes institutions et puis elles
ont course est un quartier entier qui va
changer de visage après une refonte de
la dalle du quartier principal 17 mars
il y aura également l'ouverture d'une
nouvelle école de musique on débute ce
journal avec le numérique à l'école
justement cet après midi la direction
académique des yvelines présentait un
bilan des différentes actions menées sur
le territoire et présenter les nouveaux
projets à venir l'objectif c'est
d'accélérer le déploiement de cet outil
le reportage de nicolas kirillovitch
robot appareils photo table est le
numérique à l'école est devenue
incontournable dans les classes et
notamment dans celle des yvelines huit
mille ordinateurs
4500 tablette est plus de deux mille
tableaux numériques interactifs équipe
les écoles du département d outil devenu
indispensable
avec le temps je pense que pour leur
apprentissage c'est une source de
motivation
pour apprendre à travers le jeu et à
travers des activités un peu plus
ludique que le manuel
papier c'est toujours de rigueur mais
qui
je pense doit cibler c'est aussi la
place au matin numérique et pour inciter
les équipes pédagogiques et les
collectivités à investir dans le
numérique à l'école la direction
académique de versailles lance de
nouveaux projets l'accent est porté sur
les robots un objet fascinant pour les
écoliers autre nouveauté cette année
yves il en yvelines pour raconter sa
ville en numérique et ville en yvelines
c'est un projet où les classes sont
amenés à présenter leur ville avec le
numérique présenté sa ville quand on est
en petite section de maternelle c'est
peut-être montrer les couleurs de sa
ville et puis à la fois quand on va être
dans une classe de cm ça va être de
travailler sur le passé les traces
l'histoire de la ville mais également l'
architecture
la géométrie de la ville pour découvrir
le travail des élèves sur l'ensemble du
département y ville en yvelines dispose
d'un site internet
une journée de mobilisation soutenue par
l'île de france et par l'urss le sport
scolaire était organisée aujourd'hui
dans toutes les îles de loisirs de la
région pour soutenir la candidature de
paris aux jeux olympiques de 2024 à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus de 700
jeunes venus de tout le département pour
participer à des animations sportives
l'opération a été baptisée sobrement
jo-2000 24 au programme initiation à des
raids découverte des activités
olympiques tels que le canoë le biathlon
ou encore le vtt on écoute quelques
réactions au micro de michael et demi
d'euros cet événement montre de la jeune
génération est engagée pour paris dès
1904 et nous donne un maximum de chance
de montrer au monde que cette jeune
génération francilienne croit aux jeux
parce que c'est son avenir c'est son
développement qui est en jeu et nous
nous voulons que ces jeux c'est soit les
jeux de cette nouvelle génération
évidemment parce que c'est la génération
et qui sera
la génération des athlètes de 2024 mais
aussi parce que cette génération
construit l'île de france de demain
est citoyenneté laïcité identité des
mots qui n'ont jamais eu autant de place
dans le débat public au qu'aujourd'hui
mais nos enfants savent style de quoi il
s'agit ici les parents et l'école sont
là pour expliquer bien évidemment la
ville a aussi son rôle à jouer des
collégiens de magny les hameaux ont
ainsi participé à un rallye citoyen pour
mieux comprendre tous les enjeux un
sujet de alors l'anguille
conseil municipal extraordinaire ce
matin à magny les hameaux cette classe
de collégiens s'essaie à l'exercice non
sans difficulté
[Musique]
comment fonctionne une mairie comment
sont élus le maire et ses adjoints c'est
ce que ces enfants de tenter de
comprendre rien après dans un conseil
municipal
comment on élus les les adjoints au
maire
j'ai appris aussi comme en élus le maire
comment ça se passe les débats et cetera
c'est à cet âge là que sa rentrée ils
ont besoin d'entendre ces valeurs il
découvre plein de choses aussi parce que
par exemple l'élection du maire il
pensait que c'était les habitants
donc là ça permet de leur dire qu'en
fait non c'est le conseil municipal
au même moment dehors leurs camarades
ont le droit à un cours d'histoire ou
plutôt un cours 2009 ont des houles ah
oui
non non
c'est presque ça ça s'appelle
le carré de mémoire ces anciens
combattants de la guerre d'algérie
partagent leurs souvenirs plus ou moins
douloureux dans l'espoir de rappeler à
ces jeunes esprits qu'il ne faut pas
oublier le passé et que la guerre est
toujours évitable une des façons de
perpétuer la mémoire c'est de raconter
ce qui s'est passé afin que ce ne soit
pas oublié
c'est de leur faire comprendre que la
guerre c'est par la solution dans une
actualité entachée par le terrorisme et
d'autres crises ces leçons de civisme et
de vivre ensemble ont plus que jamais
leur place
et pendant que la ville de magny les
hameaux organise sa semaine de la
citoyenneté celle de la verrière
proposons rendez vous dédié aux seniors
c'est en ce moment et jusqu'au 29
octobre aujourd'hui mercredi un défi
avec les plus jeunes étaient proposés
demain jeudi le sujet sera plus sérieux
avec une conférence pour sensibiliser au
démarchage à domicile et à la vente
forcée programme complet de l'événement
sur le site de la ville
nous partons à présent pour elancourt ou
le quartier 17 mar n'a pas fini de se
transformer nous vous en parlions il ya
quelques semaines avec elle la
rénovation de la dalle principal est
bien un autre projet va aussi le voir le
jour en 2017 c'est une nouvelle école de
musique les anciens locaux du centre
oecuméniques seront réhabilités pour
accueillir quelques 500 élèves une
quinzaine de salles sont prévues
précision camille lambert
trois ans qu'il était à l'abandon en
2017 l'ancien centre cuménique 17 mar va
s'offrir une seconde vie il deviendra la
nouvelle école de musique d'elancourt
construit en 1975 il sera complètement
transformé pour accueillir les 500
élèves de l'actuelle école de musique
jugée inadaptée l'ancienne école de
musique est donc dans la maison de
quartier de la joue où on a un centre
médical certes on a même augmenté le
nombre de stationnements puisqu'on a
fait des aménagements mais il faut
avouer que quand toutes les associations
arrive au même temps au même moment et
que vous avez des gens qui vont au
centre médical impossible de se garer
vers de temps c'est pas facile non plus
pour sécuriser la dépose des enfants
installés au coeur du centre ville elle
sera donc plus accessible le bâtiment de
730 mètres carrés accueillera une
quinzaine de salles dont six studios une
salle de percussions et une salle
d'audition un projet attendu depuis une
quinzaine d'années sur le plan
architectural le rendu se veut moderne
avec l'utilisation de briques à jour et
vous allez avoir effectivement par
rapport à l'ensemble du bâtiment une
peau qui va entourer le bâtiment qui
aura une double utilisation isolation
phonique et puis aussi permettre par
rapport en fait aux vitres vous voyez au
dessus avec les fameuses briques est
qu'ils seront à jour et d'avoir un
éclairage naturel qui rentrera dans le
bâtiment équipé d'une technologie
intelligente l'infrastructure sera le
premier bâtiment domotique d'elancourt
coût des travaux plus de 2 millions
d'euros financés par la ville une
opération qui s'inscrit dans la volonté
d'apporter de l'animation et du
dynamisme sur la dalle 17 mar ouverture
prévue fin 2010 cette
culture vendredi soir dernier à
guyancourt à la batterie se produisait
sages comme des sauvages un groupe
franco gréco-américaine au corso
bruxellois avec leur blues ou pigray
couleurs cavaquinho brésilien il propose
des mélodies forcément métissée
on n'est pas contre et on est content de
faire ça mais ça s'est fait vraiment par
hasard mais comme nous vivons st
ma mère est américaine mon père est
français et j'ai grandi en grèce donc
déjà ça fait trois identités que j'ai
pas choisi c'est comme ça et puis ils se
mêlent c'est un peu pareil ça s'est
baladé par tous on récolte un peu ce
qu'il nous plaît on ne mélange nous et
le point sur l'actualité culturelle le
journal de la culture c'est chaque
mercredi 18h45 sur tv fil 78 les propos
recueillis ce week-end par camille
lambert sport et équitation à présent
nous vous proposons de découvrir plus
précisément l'équitation en amazone
cette discipline créée au xvième siècle
par catherine de médicis qui consiste à
monter à cheval avec les jambes du même
côté dans les yvelines c'est au château
de plaisir que son proposer des baptêmes
mais quel ennemi dans
l'herbe ossian pratiquer l'équitation en
amazone depuis dix ans aux écuries du
château de plaisir cette discipline
consiste à chevaucher avec les jambes du
même côté du cheval la technique a été
inventé au xvième siècle par les femmes
de la royauté c'est une discipline assez
ancienne qui était réservée aux dames
noble nous avons des écuyères amazon
très célèbre sissi impératrice que tout
le monde connaît qui monte est
parfaitement en amazone et qui
pratiquaient toutes les disciplines de
l'amazone donc le dressage tout le monde
a vu six 6 sauter un beau bosquet de
fleurs pour monte en amazone mais
cavalière s'habille généralement avec
une veste cintrée et une jupe longue le
cheval est lui équipé d'une salle
spéciale composée d'un seul étrillé à
gauche et de deux fourches pour enrouler
la jambe la jambe gauche vient se caler
sous la fourche inférieur par rapport à
une scène classique la selle et flatte
le siège est bien en arrière et bien
plat une selle qui modifie les
sensations en loisir ou en compétition
la position des mains est primordial en
amazone est plus complexe il faut
vraiment avoir une main fixe parce que
comme on n'a pas de jambes à droite la
badine nom qui est la grande cravache
qu'on a à ma droite qui remplace notre
de jambe droite si on a les maquis bouge
on fait peur à notre cheval est notre
cheval ne comprend pas les ordres qu'on
va lui donner pour tester cette
discipline des baptêmes sont programmées
régulièrement aux écuries du château de
plaisir claire de son côté espère
pratiques et l'amazone pendant encore
une dizaine d'années
certains se déplacent tâche ovale mais
d'autres préfèrent malgré tout la
voiture mais ils se soucient tout autant
de l'environnement bonne nouvelle pour
eux 28 stations de véhicules électriques
vont voir le jour à saint quentin en
yvelines d'ici à 2017 après le chesnay
ou encore versailles il sera possible
d'utiliser ce mode de transport dès l'an
prochain à travers les 12 communes de
l'agglomération les négociations sont
toujours en cours avec la société
autolib selon nos confrères du parisien
il devrait en coûter à saint quentin en
yvelines à l'agglomération qu'elle que
60000 euros par station on notera que ce
projet devait initialement voir le jour
cet automne merci de nous avoir suivi
tous les reportages sont à retrouver sur
le
www.tv5monde.com vous en avez à
l'habitude prochain journal demain aux
horaires habituels
[Musique]